[Music]
for me
superman has always been such a hugely
important character i was a little kid
when superman the movie came out and of
course that's sort of the dawn
of our modern superhero storytelling and
i imprinted on that like a baby duckling
i was always fascinated with superman i
was especially intrigued by krypton it
was fascinating to me that you had this
entire world that was so advanced and so
brilliant in so many ways
and yet so completely incapable of
seeing the obvious and that's the driver
behind the entire superman story
the premise is that you have these two
young people on krypton who are from
very different
castes or levels of society within
krypton and
krypton as we know is in very serious
trouble and
they're coming to understand that their
planet has a lot of problems that their
culture is completely unwilling and even
unable to recognize and they're
beginning to figure out why that is
sarah is an ur which is a group
designed to be
soldiers
military personnel
she has no
fear for her own mortality
zhan meanwhile is a ray and he is from
the upper hierarchy of the planet and
he's being raised to be
a scientist and a leader in the most
elite academies
he however has always understood that
something's a little bit off there's
everyone else is in lockstep and zan is
not
also and this is important for the story
he is laura's younger cousin
and uh they have always had a
relationship that's really more like big
sister little brother when the story
began zan and sarah had had a bit of an
attraction to each other but neither of
them ever seriously thought that was
going to go anywhere
but the events of book one
have
brought them together
and made them understand that they're
really two of the only people
who
are looking at some of these problems
and some of these issues and it's
created this very strong bond between
them
[Music]
some of the differences that i wanted to
stress were the importance of genetic
editing and genetic engineering in
krypton
you are literally
who you were designed to be on this
planet and in this one jorel and laura
are fairly young they're sort of the
young rebels in this scientific
community and on this planet and they're
not so separated from the main
characters
[Music]
he has just been amazing throughout i
put these descriptions on the page and
i'm hopeful like oh will he understand
this and not only does eric understand
it he's like this alchemist he just
transmutes it into something that's even
more dazzling and complex and awesome
[Music]
[Music]
you